question 25 with the advent of modern
physics and the contradictions to
classical physics has there been any
change in chemistry is there any scope
for further change is so bad hmm well
here I'm not a physicist I'm sort of
like I don't really fully understand the
contradictions with classical physics I
i mean i think my feeling is that and i
think is true in the ball correspondence
principle that classical physics is a an
extreme form of quantum mechanics in the
bulk regime so the muster must they
can't really be a contradiction i think
it's just that some physics started from
things you could see and do experiments
and as we got rather clever people like
Dalton Dalton and others realize that
gases were made of very small things
that we couldn't see and then we had to
conjecture this and in fact isn't
interesting to think about chemistry
because i think the chemist is really
bit different from many other people
because we do think in terms of this
invisible molecular world an example is
water when I look at a glass of water I
instinctively am still thinking about
the water molecules and the way in which
these interactions occur and that the
bulk effects of this fascinating and
texture of water is a consequence of the
hydrogen bonding behavior in it what it
feels different from acetone and petrol
and and other liquids and so chemists
have this molecular perspective and I
don't know when it when it when I got it
you know it sort of somehow you sort of
announce that it couldn't have always
been there but somehow you glide into
this molecular
the world and see things in different
way from most other people eaten
properly physicists and biologists and
that's interesting so okay i'm not sure
i'm able to answer that question between
nathan the quantum world and the
classical world I do know because I'm a
spectroscopy that I've studied the
interaction of radiation with matter and
by looking at the patterns in the
spectrum and by analyzing them we can
gently come to a conclusion about the
structure of the molecule soul of the
bond length of this length and and I
understand the motion of these things
and then but in a sense it's a bit of an
abstract world and by looking at these
spectra and analyzing the data and
coming up with bond lengths between
atoms in molecules likes they thought I
acid aldehyde one one of the first
molecules we looked at where we
determine the structure you use you sort
of forget that it's a quantum picture
and that you you think of it in terms of
a physical object but you know that it's
oscillating and it has these models so
somehow you are locked into a classical
picture of the molecular world which is
a little bit suspect I think because
that molecular picture doesn't tell you
anything but we know now quite a lot of
the ways in which we take that very
physical ball-and-stick picture with a
pinch of salt and we understand you know
the electrons or electron distributions
and when we draw a stick between our
line between a hydrogen and an oxygen
atom it's really electron density so
there
much of a conflict in my mind it's more
that we have a somewhat restricted
picture based on our physical world but
we need that as a framework to hang the
quantum mechanics on the quantum the
mathematics is correct and it's the
mathematics that really is correct more
correct is the language through in which
we understand that world and that's not
easy to explain to other people and that
quantum mechanical picture the ways that
work it can be very very beautiful and
elegant em in the way that a picture is
elegant and an asked a brilliant
architectural design to solve a bridge
problem or whatever is is beautiful and
it's a tragedy perhaps that so few
people don't have sufficient
mathematical fluency to appreciate the
elegance ways in which nature works and
and that's the language in which as fine
said nature speaks and that's totally
separated from most people and and in a
sense that's bad for science because
they don't really recognize that there
are passages written by nature which are
as beautiful as that passages written by
Shakespeare I know example is is Ben Z
my wife Margaret said you know Ben sees
that thing that smelly thinking that
people think I'll frightened and that's
that's what
real people think but in fact benzene is
is too organic chemistry what make Beth
is to Shakespeare or Hamlet sister
Shakespeare and it's a sort of
cornerstone its structure and it was
behavior in aromatic chemistry's this is
so fundamental so elegant and we have
some hand waving mathematics as well
involved and trying to explain why it's
such an important molecule in the whole
of organic chemistry and blue living
system chemistry as well so for me it's
not so much a conflict between classical
and quantum mechanics but more important
is the separation of people who don't
have a good science stroke mathematical
fluency from an understanding of the way
the world works I mean mobile phones and
based on things like Maxwell's equations
Fineman began said the most important
breakthrough the 19th century was
Maxwell's equations and he said in ten
thousand years time when the Civil War
will be just sort of provincial little
skirmish in the mists of time Maxwell's
equations will still be the key an
important aspect of the way that the
technologies of that underpin that world
will work as if we live that one I hope
that will do it's not what your answer
to your question but it's usually the
case I don't often the answer the
questions though I'm asked that's
probably because they're doing to
understand the questions and or maybe if
they do I don't know what the answer is
so I usually answer something else
question 25 with the advent of modern
physics and the contradictions to
classical physics has there been any
change in chemistry is there any scope
for further change if so where
hmm well yeah I'm not a physicist I'm
sort of like I don't really fully
understand the contradictions with
classical physics I i mean i think my
feeling is that and i think is true in
the ball correspondence principle that
classical physics is a an extreme form
of quantum mechanics in the bulk regime
so and the muster must they can't really
be a contradiction i think it's just
that some physics started from things
you could see and do experiments and as
we got rather clever people like Dalton
Dalton and others realize that gases
were made of very small things that we
couldn't see and then we had to
conjecture this and in fact isn't
interesting to think about chemistry
because i think the chemist is really
bit different from many other people
because we do think in terms of this
invisible molecular world an example is
water when I look at a glass of water I
instinctively am still thinking about
the water molecules and the way in which
these interactions occur and that the
bulk effect of this fascinating and
texture of water is a consequence of the
hydrogen bonding behavior in it what it
feels different from acetone and petrol
and and other liquids and so chemists
have this molecular perspective and I
don't know when it when it when I got it
you know I thought of some how you sort
of mass that it couldn't have always
been there but somehow you glide into
this molecular world and see things in
different way from most other people
eaten probably physicists and biologists
and
that's interesting so okay i'm not sure
i'm able to answer that question between
nathan the quantum world and the the
classical world I do know because I'm a
spectroscopy that I studied the
interaction of radiation with matter and
by looking at the patterns of in the
spectrum and by analyzing them we can
gently come to a conclusion about the
structure of the molecule soul of the
bond length of this length and and I
understand the motion of these things
and then but in a sense it's a bit of an
abstract world and by looking at these
spectra and analyzing the data and
coming up with bond lengths between
atoms in molecules like they throw acid
aldehyde when one of the first molecules
we looked at where we determine the
structure you use you sort of forget
that it's a quantum picture and that you
you think of it in terms of a physical
object but you know that it's
oscillating and it has these models so
somehow you are locked into a classical
picture of the molecular world which is
a little bit suspect I think because
that molecular picture doesn't tell you
anything but we know now quite a lot of
the ways in which we take that very
physical ball-and-stick picture with a
pinch of salt and we understand you know
the electrons or electron distributions
and when we draw a stick between our
line between a hydrogen and an oxygen
atom it's really electron density so
there isn't much of a conflict in my
mind it's more that we have a somewhat
restricted picture based on our physical
world
but we need that as a framework to hang
the quantum mechanics on the quantum the
mathematics is correct and it's the
mathematics that really is correct more
correct is the language through in which
we understand that world and that's not
easy to explain to other people and that
quantum mechanical picture the ways that
work it can be very very beautiful and
elegant in the way that a picture is
elegant and an Astra a brilliant
architectural design to solve a bridge
problem or whatever is is beautiful and
it's a tragedy may perhaps that so few
people don't have sufficient
mathematical fluency to appreciate the
elegance ways in which nature works and
and that's the language in which as fine
said nature speaks and that's totally
separated from most people and and in a
sense that's bad for science because
they don't really recognize that there
are passages written by nature which are
as beautiful as the passages written by
Shakespeare I mean the example is as
benzene my wife Margaret said you know
Ben sees that thing that smelly thinking
that people think I'll Brighton that's
that's what they're real people think
but in fact benzene is is too organic
chemistry what make Beth is to
Shakespeare or Hamlet sister Shakespeare
and it's a sort of
cornerstone its structure and it was
behavior in aromatic else trees this is
so fundamental so elegant and we have
some hand waving mathematics as well
involved and try to explain why it's
such an important molecule in the whole
of organic chemistry and blue living
system chemistry as well so for me it's
not so much a conflict between classical
and quantum mechanics but more important
is the the separation of people who
don't have a good science stroke
mathematical fluency from an
understanding of the way the world works
I mean mobile phones and based on things
like Maxwell's equations Fineman began
said the most important breakthrough the
19th century was Maxwell's equations and
he said in ten thousand years time when
the Civil War will be just sort of
provincial little skirmish in the mists
of time Maxwell's equations will still
be the key an important aspect of the
way that the technologies of that
underpin that world will work as if we
live that one I hope that will do is not
much an answer to your question but it's
usually the case I don't often answer
the questions that I mass that's
probably because they're doing to
understand the questions and or maybe if
they do I don't know what the answer is
so I usually under pants or something
else